you know it really is still impossible
to process that one year ago
today we lost kobe bryant you know he
was a great basketball player
but in his second act in life he had
become so much more a producer
entrepreneur oscar winner and most
importantly an incredible dad
a girl dad yeah and of course our hearts
break for vanessa who lost the love of
her life
and the daughter who was set to carry on
kobe's basketball legacy
what we try to do is just you know just
be who we are love each other love our
family and
just keep one foot in front of the other
keep moving according to our e.t
source vanessa is following those
footsteps today she will spend the one
year anniversary reminiscing
and celebrating kobe and gigi's lives
privately with those closest to her
one thing is for sure their legacies are
not forgotten it's going to be a year
since we lost kobe have you even been
able to still wrap your brain around
that
no i'm still having trouble sleeping
posted a tribute online and last night
kobe's good friend kyrie irving
arrived to the brooklyn nets game in
bryant's number eight lakers jersey
on instagram vanessa posted a heartfelt
letter from
one of gigi's best friends which read in
part quote i hope that in the midst of
your intense sadness
you catch a glimpse of joy in who the
daughter you created and raised was
you did it right mrs bryant in vanessa's
caption she said
it still doesn't seem real kobe we did
it right
gigi you still make mommy proud prior to
kobe's death vanessa was always
incredibly private but knowing
how much kobe and his fans shared a
special bond
vanessa made her instagram public
it's clear natalia bianca and baby capri
have kept vanessa going through her
unimaginable paintings
vanessa shared their milestones like
baby capri's first steps last may
and her first words just last month what
are you eating
good job orange
you say it like daddy daddy says orange
it's no secret kobe was a disney fanatic
so for bianca's fourth birthday
vanessa went all out with a cinderella
themed party
vanessa has also worked hard to keep
kobe's book legacy alive what does that
feel like to be number one with the book
in a project that you love so much
it's a crazy feeling to be number one in
new york times it's a great feeling
that was kobe's last e.t interview
before his passing when the second
installment of his new york times
best-selling book series
epica the river of sand was released
vanessa revealed the one thing she had
to change
to honor his mamba mentality there was
one line
in this book that said friends come
first practice comes second
there is no way in hell kobe would ever
agree to because he used to always tell
the kids your friends will be there
after practice thank you all so much for
being here
e.t was at staples center for kobe's
memorial service in february
vanessa delivered a heartbreaking 21
minute eulogy
which was difficult at times for her to
get through
we didn't get the chance to teach her
how to drive a car
i won't be able to tell her how gorgeous
she looks on her wedding day
beyonce christina aguilera and alicia
keys all performed
in attendance were j-lo and a-rod kim
and kanye
l.l cool j and queen latifah vanessa's
been leaning on her inner circle of
friends to cope with her grief
including sierra and lala anthony who
told us she's there
to lift her up through the darkness you
know she's had so many painful days was
you know the tick tocks that you guys
shared when you were just laughing
and giggling and being girls and because
sometimes
that's a road to healing i'm definitely
that person i come in like okay
what are we doing today i always say you
know to see your smile and laugh
to me is the greatest feeling r b singer
monica has also been a pillar of support
for vanessa
each day is a struggle and i think
whatever she's feeling each day
is not something any of us will ever
understand that level of pain that level
of heartache
and so being there i just enjoy the kids
they are the greatest blessing and they
are the greatest gift that he left
you know this really is one of my
favorite pictures of kobe um he's on
vacation in italy
with bianca in the baby bjorn and i want
you to listen to him
light up talking about her she has so
much energy
it's outrageous the kid does not stop
like we call it a little mini tornado
that's who kobe bryant was and we miss
[Music]
him